alo
alo cho bạn
Hôm nay thì ở như lịch cũ thì mình sẽ
alo mày không nghe rõ rồi tôi
như lịch cũ mình sẽ
em vừa gắn chữa cho các bạn các nhóm đồ
án cũng nhờ thứ bảy tâm sự con thứ mày
không thể tâm sự tuổi hồng lại được
ba
chấm + chữa cho các nhóm
cho em
ờ
ờ không biết tuần qua miếu thế nào
mình có vẻ là Ừ Có phải nhóm và nhóm có
vẻ chuẩn bị tốt hơn so với mấy cái nhóm
trước rồi
các clip tay
trước về phân tích thiết kế cơ sở dữ
liệu hả anh ở
để làm gì quan trọng là như thế trước đã
nếu mà những người Tôi hơi ốm đi nếu mà
nếu mà bạn học were cốt là để mở phục vụ
cho học làm bác en Giống như mình đang
dậy như này
thì đúng là về sau nếu mà ông chuyên sâu
hơn
Ừ thì à Học thêm về thiết kế thì càng
tốt càng tốt thôi ở đây nó sẽ bài toán
đó là
bài toán nó sẽ là kiểu ông học để phục
vụ cái gì nhưng mà ông học thì mà chuyên
về thiết kế cơ sở dữ liệu chuyên về kiểu
mảng 3p sẽ làm ông phải học tất cả lên
cái Winner bây giờ đây điều hiển nhiên
là họ còn nếu mà ông học word để mà làm
lập trình viên báo cand thì được ra ông
chỉ cần biết qua thôi Cái qua về quê
thôi Bởi bởi thực tế nhá thực tế đó là
ông nắm rõ về câu truy vấn hơn là về
thiết kế cơ sở liệu vì cái công việc của
thiết kế cơ sở dữ liệu là công việc của
người khác chứ không phải là công việc
của ông chứ Khi ông có rất nhiều năm
kinh nghiệm và chuyên về tốc bay và sự
giống như ở tôi ở trên công ty thì tôi
tôi kể kiến thức của tôi hiện tại thì ở
cũng tương đối về tôi thích tìm hiểu để
quên em nữa với ông để kĩ là thật ra tôi
dậy mà our rất là có tâm Có lẽ là sau
ngoại Bởi tôi rất thích wet tìm hiểu mày
nó tôi không tìm hiểu toán mấy mà tôi
tìm hiểu về kiểu cấu trúc các thứ tư đấy
thì thì là tôi còn được động và một ít
một ít về cái phần thiết kế thì may ra
đấy ở 1 điểm nó cũng là điểm có lợi
không ạ Nhưng mà thường ở một công ty
lớn thì nó sẽ rạch ròi là một người một
người chuyên để mà làm về cơ sở liệu
thậm chí có hẳn một nhóm chuyên về cái
đấy chứ không phải lập trình gì cả Còn
anh em mình lập trình chị có truy vấn cơ
sở dữ liệu người ta đã dậy dựng sẵn nên
là Thực ra nếu mà họ thấy ý của bạn ấy
thì là không cần phải học với cái Phân
tích khổ thơ thứ nhưng mà nếu mà Mấy ông
thấy tôi đang dậy gà tôi có dậy luôn cả
phần đấy nghĩa là tôi dậy ngay từ cái
lập trình web cơ bản tôi nó dậy mấy ông
ấy cách thiết kế các thủ thứ nhưng mà và
đặc biệt là nào đồ án web chuyên sâu này
tôi cũng dậy trong mấy ông này mới cái
đấy à không để cho mấy ông đa dạng về
cái việc cái á
đa dạng người ông hiểu từ đầu đến cuối
là một cái cu trách là gồm những giai
đoạn nào và mấy ông thấy phù hợp nhất ở
những giai đoạn nào giờ sử gia sử dạng
như là gặp ông Làm lập trình từ đây đến
cuối không cảm thấy thật ra ông khó chịu
với màng Online giống như tôi ở ngọn thì
ông sẽ chưa sôi bác em cái chẳng hạn thế
ông ngoại thích cậu mày mò Tìm hiểu về
were hơn chẳng hạn thế ông muốn cứ Cả
ngày chỉ ngồi nghĩ về câu truy vấn ứng
kiểu tôi rằng ăn thì ông tìm hiểu về bên
sâu hơn người queo về cơ sở liệu vân vân
đối ngoại là sử Ông thích kiểu công việc
nhàm chán hơn ống thích kiểu chích làm
tài liệu thôi chả bạn thì ông sẽ làm đi
ấy ông sẽ ngồi phân tích và ngồi viết
tài liệu nếu không hiểu thì thôi Không
cái
ờ ờ
có mấy thằng kia có trò xóa rồi hoàn tác
Đúng rồi bạn này hỏi câu rất hay thôi
Hồi mà tôi ngồi Hồi trước tôi cũng
thường ai để ý cái vụ đấy là biết là
thằng good day chẳng hạn hồi thấy điển
hình nhất cái cho à Xóa so với khôi phục
thì thì bản chất là xóa thì rất khó khôi
phục nữa mà Xóa thẳng nó hoặc nó không
thể căn sơn rét Giống như là ở ở bên anh
ạ
anh không Sao mà
Thì à nó không phải hiểu cơn sốt rét
giống như ở trên Windows được không ạ
Nhưng mà nó có hiển thị nút hoàn tác thì
cài á cái việc hoàn tác đấy ế đó bản
chất là mình mình chưa Xóa cứng ở trên
database mà mình xóm mềm nó giống như
mấy bạn kia đang nói là xóm mềm và xóa
delete tới gà Mình sẽ lưu lại là mình đã
xóa
đấy nhưng mà bạn chất vào nó chưa hề Xóa
dùng từ nhà tôi tôi có làm ngay trong
cái đồ ăn á làm kia cũng có cái cốt và
xóa mềm đấy nếu mà ông nhớ
em tắt đi mở lại nhé
ở đây Tôi có một cái bảng xóm 10 mà xóa
đi led là là đi hết rồi tắt này thì thì
giả sử vào mặc định thì cột này sẽ là
nung như này nghĩa là chưa Hay bị xóa
Còn nếu ra sự là tôi cho nó khoảng thời
gian như này chẳng ngại thì thì mặc định
thằng level nó cũng có cơ chế rồi nó sẽ
kiểm tra xem mà sẽ chỉ lấy những cái cột
vào là cái nào là đi thật là luôn thôi
thì nó mới hiển thị ra còn như này nó sẽ
không bơi hiển thị là nữa để trừ khi ông
phải thêm cái là Wechat tất cả với thùng
rác đấy Hoa with police là chị vừa những
đã cài đã xóa thì mới hiển thị những cái
này thì cái này có một điểm hay nữa Tại
sao tại sao mình phải lưu lại cả thời
gian mà mình không chỉ cần lưu lại là
chua Phone này mà biết được là là nó nó
nó đã xóa chưa gửi lưu lại thời gian này
rất phù hợp cho việc và vì sau ông sẽ
chạy một cái hệ thống tự động xử như
thằng google photo được ạ Có thể loại
bảo là cho thùng rác 60 ngày sau đó thì
sau 6 hai quả nghĩa là nó sẽ chạy nó
khái niệm là con chó Tức là nó chạy tự
động cứ định kỳ theo một khoảng thời
gian ví dụ là cứ sau sau 30 60 ngày thì
nó sẽ đầu tiên là thực ra ngày nào nó
chạy thuốc chứa phút nào Nóng chạy đấy
phút nào nó chạy được thì kiểm tra xem
mà thằng này đã đủ số 30 ngày 60 ngày
chưa để mà nó xóa hiểu không Nó sẽ mặc
định lấy ra tất cả những bản ghi nào
trong cái phạm vi đấy rồi nó sẽ xóa thế
thôi lúc đấy sẽ xóa cứng lúc đấy khó
khôi phục hơn bởi vì khôi phục bây giờ
thì nó liên quan đến khôi phục cả phần
cứng chứ không phải liên quan Khôi phục
phần mềm lưu lại trong cơ sở dữ liệu nữa
có một sự thật đắng cay đó là cho dù là
đấy ông kia mà bảo nó lừa đúng không lẽ
màn Chắc là xóa thời gian nó xóm mềm
nghĩa là để nó không nhận chị ra nữa
nhưng mà trong thùng rác nó vẫn có thể
hạn đúng không như có một sự thật nữa đó
là Ừ tôi từng xóa cứng hơn ở trong thùng
rác rồi thôi tôi có ngắn hở cho thằng
Google sport và thằng Google sóc bọn nó
khôi phục của tôi từ trước đến nay tôi
không ạ nghĩa là bản chất là nó vẫn
không phản là xóa mà nó vẫn nó vẫn lưu
lại ở trên bộ nhớ nó thằng Google nó
chơi rất là mạnh về khoản là ổ cứng của
nó để bộ nhờ nó rất rộng Nó hoàn toàn là
nó phải lưu lại vĩnh viễn ở trên lại
được nhưng mà đương nhiên là tôi có trả
tiền cho cái Google one two là hiểu Gần
như thành viên của nó không phải hẳn
thành viên vip và của việc cái đấy là nó
là gói 100gb
day Nhung chị tốn thì 49 một tháng thôi
nhưng mà cái đấy ngoài việc là nó tăng
giới hạn của ai đó sẽ đưa cho ông là
Google one thành viên Google one thì nó
có cái điểm Lợi 100 điểm lợi mà tôi
thường hay thường hay làm nhất đó là tôi
nhắn tin trực tiếp với cho support ở bên
nó lại tôi cho bé uống xe này thì nhờ
tôi có từng đề cập vụ đấy rồi
mà tôi từng có ý kiến bất kỳ ý kiến gì
rồi sẽ liền gọi nó
mình có gì Những cảm không nhỉ Ok không
đi nữa cảm đấy thì ai giờ sửa nó sport
nha hết phải mà cái tôi đang tài khoản
Google
100g nha đã có thể công tác Ớt này đứng
yên bằng tiếng Anh nhá tiếng Việt thực
ra vẫn có nhưng mà phải là sự ra nhà
chẳng
chị
sẽ ăn gì là phải cái rồi Có
ai đi chọn một cái gì đó như này đúng
không ai xong rồi có thể chat trực tiếp
nó luôn này da xịn đấy
với kiện ông để nó tiếng Anh còn nếu có
tiếng Việt thì nó sẽ chỉ có
hỗ trợ con Mail thôi chứ chưa Tiếng Anh
ở mấy ông trưởng bập bẹ mày cái cô tiếng
Anh cơ bản là được rồi này
Ừ
ok chưa ạ
giờ cho mẹ em không còn thắc mắc gì nữa
thì mình lại tiếp tục chấm thôi ông ạ
Vừa rồi tôi thành nhóm đầu tiên đã có
kiểu có mi các thứ thứ rồi ngoại có
Optimus
Đây có tài liệu này
khu resort có mấy hai cái tên xem nhé
Ừ cái là
lại vẫn đang thiên hướng à và có có sẵn
cốt trước phải làm cốt rồi sinh ra diện
ra như tôi đã bảo nếu phải vẽ chứ không
phải là mấy ông cốt sao gọi có giao diện
hoặc mày không phải vẽ rồi mình từ để
mới có Ok ở đây là gì nhỉ
cho tôi được khi thói quen sử mấy ông
làm cái gì luôn cơ để tả gì người ông
Táo Em hiểu không phải viết Kris mi có
cái rõ cái tờ Đạt đề tài nhỉ
mi của mấy ông bây giờ đang bị mặc định
của lại khi tôi quên sự để tải mấy ông
thật
cho người béo có thay đổi tài nữa mà ừ
nhà nóc y à không mình không cần tính
đang nói gì ở đây đã đúng không Anh Thư
đó Có gì trả nghĩa gì cả
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
tao xem mà điểm danh này Ừ cho làm hệ
thống điểm danh đó thì chị ra chọn môn
chọn lớp mà chỉ toàn bộ sinh viên đi học
nghỉ học có phép cái số 4.000 cái này
thật ra bạn biết là mẹ sao bởi vì cái
này đúng biểu giao diện của ở trên
trường của tôi bạn lại ôm Nguyên về ạ
nhưng mà đây là một trong cái rất hay bé
uống tham khảo đó bản chất là thứ nhất
là chọn Thực ra là ở đây là họ lỡ chọn
môn ở đây nó phải nên có ghi chú nữa thì
còn tốt là những môn vào lớp đã được
mình đã được phân công thôi Đấy sau đó
mấy mình để toàn bộ sinh viên của lớp
đấy Sau đó thì mặc định đầu tiên tích là
mặc định đi học như hai mà mình thể đổi
tích lại để nó thành nghỉ học hai có
phép chứ không phải là điền từng sinh
viên một đấy sau đó khi mỗi lần cập nhật
thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra là cụ thể là sinh
viên này sẽ cảnh báo là sinh viên này
thật sự ra kiểu như này sinh viên này bị
phá án bị cấm thi là Nhạn khi mà cái này
nó lớn hơn 5 đó là sự thế là sự thế đấy
tùy miếu quý đó anh tưởng thế nó có thể
hiển thị màu màu da cam mình báo màu đỏ
là chị bị cấm rồi chẳng hạn Nếu hiểu rồi
không ai đấy một cái rất là hay bởi vì
giáo viên hoàn toàn thể linh động sinh
viên đấy là sự sinh viên đấy Bị nghĩ quá
nhiều nhưng mà sinh viên đã học được
chẳng hạn Vân đúng ạ sau đó hiển thị ra
ở dưới này nữa là tổng số sinh viên đi
học trên tổng số sinh viên Có bằng 12
nữa gọi cho mà đây là một giao diện tuổi
từng làm cho trường của tôi để theo và
nó con mặc định là nó sẽ lấy là khung
giờ này theo khung giờ mà ông đang đang
truy cập và sử là bây giờ là Giả sử có
cho Bây giờ là 8 giờ sáng hạn không khi
vào thì mặc định nó sẽ điểm danh cho cả
sáng luôn là thứ 8 giờ đến 12 giờ chẳng
thế chứ không phải là Hiển thị ra là
những cái ca khác bởi mình nó mới có
chuyện mình điểm của anh cho những cá
khác được Ngoại vô lý nhưng không được
điểm danh sớm quá mình không được phát
triển anh muộn quá ở trong là đúng theo
khung giờ của mình đang Chị đăng nhập
thôi Khi mình suy nghĩ ra đái xong mình
sẽ đơn giản ở nút điểm danh Nói chung à
Nếu giả sử Mình cứ đọc sinh viên các thứ
trong một tích tích tích tích tích mình
hoặc ít mấy ông thấy thật ra rồi sẽ rất
là ít thao tác ở đây nó ra tiện cho
người dùng là sử có thật 30 sinh viên 49
viên nữa thì mình cư đọc sinh viên thôi
tích ngoặc thực ra chỉ có một vài Sinh
viên nghỉ học thì phải thích thôi còn
không gần như sẽ lướt qua rồi điểm danh
thế là xong nếu không hiểu gì đâu không
ạ
thì ngày nay ở đây là do diện của bên
bên điểm danh và cái này sẽ bao gồm cái
thêm điểm ngành và và sửa điểm danh là
sẽ cùng một lúc luôn ở trong cái giao
diện này sửa tất cả sao Nghĩa giả sử
trong trình cái ca đấy mình vẫn có thể
vào về sửa là sự là sinh viên đấy tự
nhiên có một sinh viên đến muộn là ngã
thì các bạn em thiếu một cái là đi muộn
đấy hoàn toàn để đi muộn đi muộn thì
mình sẽ tính ở trường tôi nó sẽ là không
phải 33 chị thay vì ở một bộ nghị sẽ ra
không phải ba bụi nhỉ Đấy người ta đổi ý
muộn sẽ có mua gì cho em ạ Đấy nó sẽ
thêm một cái ở đây và tương tự Thế là sự
của ông nói đi học nhưng thực ra tích
nhầm thì mình sẽ sửa lại ngay trong ngay
trong thời ca đấy mình thể sửa được trả
nợ thế hoa mình hay Bấm vào lịch sử để
xem lại cái thời khóa biểu thì mối nguy
thực ra có giao diện đấy đấy nhưng mà
đây nhưng mà chắc là khi nào tôi sẽ cho
mấy ông xem sau hiện tại ga tội không
muốn cho mấy ông xe Bởi vì bởi vì nếu mà
tô màu cho mấy ông xem thì chả
10 10 nhóm đều giống giao diện giống hệt
nhau đều các thứ sử đều không hay nhưng
mà bạn này thì bạn đấy là sinh viên ở
trường của tôi này thì bạn đấy Nhìn qua
cái giao diện với lại lấy ý tưởng luôn
Nếu được là
mấy ông cũng nên tự sáng tạo tự nghĩ
thêm là mình nên thêm cái gì đó như mấy
ông hiểu thì tôi nữa Tôi không thích đâu
Cái này không phải là cho mỗi nhóm điểm
này nhá mà à mà là cái việc à mình phải
hiểu được là người dùng cần cái gì Cái
gì tiện cho người dùng đúng ạ đúng ạ
không phải là ba mới sinh viên mình nhập
tay 30 sinh viên tên của sinh viên rồi
Xong rồi thì địa cái sẽ lấy ông Trần Đại
nhập từng sinh viên ở nhập tầng cái buổi
thôi vãi lại chọn lại chọn lãi rồi nhập
rồi ấn nút thêm rồi nhập nhập nút thêm
để chết bọn mình sẽ làm như gửi hiển thị
ra như này điểm này mua loa rồi điểm
danh Thế là sau không ạ Nếu hãy tốn ít
nhất click có thể mà những trực quan cho
người dùng dễ nhìn thì cái phần mềm đấy
phần mềm tin đi thế thôi đúng không
Anh hiểu hiểu thôi
đăng ký sữa Cái tình trạng này bỏ qua
tình trạng chảy nghĩa thì rõ là tích
theo cái này được rồi này
Ừ
người dùng đặt thế người dùng sôi ông
ông hãy nghĩ là nếu mình là có phần mềm
như này không ạ hoặc vào thời ra đôi khi
mà không cần phải phải nghĩ quá sâu xa
đâu Ông làm ra phần mềm đúng không Sau
đó ông tét thẳng luôn Ông xem Bây giờ
tôi cho ông nhập 500 sinh viên Bởi vì
bây giờ đang có sinh viên đang học kiểu
hiện tầm 500 91 nhìn không ạ Ông nhập
1000 sinh viên Lúc và đang học đúng
không ạ Trông nhập điểm lanh cho tất cả
sinh viên đấy Giả sử là bây giờ chưa có
phần mềm sau đó có phần mềm Ông mua về ạ
người ta phải nhập một đống đấy vào dữ
liệu cũ Thảo thì làm sao nó tiện nhất
cho người dùng không ạ Ở bắt máy Ông làm
thế thì ông Nghĩa làm gì với ông dùng à
sister tạo à không không phải nhấp tay
đúng không ạ bên tay rồi Gì nhật anh cổ
gì cả tiện nhất người dùng cái ông không
nghĩ Ừ ông ông cũng lười vụ này không ạ
Ông sẽ làm đấy xong bao lâu ông ạ Ông
thử nghĩ xem
Ừ tôi không quan tâm việc của bây giờ
ông ông nhập vào bằng cái gì Nói chung
là tôi có người lấy dữ liệu ông làm kiểu
gì làm nhập vào tôi ông có thể cho chó
scan cũng được là sửa hồi trước hồi
trước là không có treo được ạ hôi trước
là điểm danh bằng giấy ạ Ông ngoại phải
chơi trò bài toán ở phải dùng thuật toán
để mà hồi trước tôi là muộn đấy đó tôi
phải phải nhận diện nhận diện chữ để mà
may Mà chữ là kiểu nó lại in ra giấy
nhưng mà mai là chữ của đánh máy chứ
không phải viết bằng tay không nhận diện
khó thể phải scan rồi mà kiểu inbox vào
chẳng hạn xử thế
Ê mấy ông cứ Hình dung là làm phần mềm
sao cho mà Bởi người dùng mua phần mềm
của mấy ông về không phải là nó bây giờ
bắt đầu về kinh doanh và xử án kinh
doanh rồi là xử nó đã có sẵn dữ liệu rồi
thì nó nhập hạn như thế nào đấy và tương
lai họ sẽ nhập và như nào nữa đấy và
nhập vào để làm gì để mà xuất ra những
cái gì để để mà nó sẽ hỗ trợ mình cái gì
không phải nhập vào cho vui hiển thị ra
đúng cái vừa nhập thì cũng chẳng giải
quyết thì cả trông thấy hoàn toàn được
nhập vào những cái này đúng không Nói để
hiển thị ra cái gì vậy chị là để quyết
định xem một sinh viên đã được thi hay
không chẳng hạn đúng không Đấy đấy cái
duy nhất của cái việc điểm danh và
ballon nữa rồi thế thành câu rồi đúng ạ
Cái đấy Cái cách tôi phân tích của một
cái bài toán là như thế Tôi muốn cho bé
uống hiểu được và lập trình viên mình
không phải là cơ cảm đâu và cốt đóng
ngoặc dẫn chứng minh Ăn mình phải hiểu
được là bài toán nó như thế nào mình
giải quyết bài toán như thế nào Thì đấy
là mục đích của cái đoàn này làm trợ
Ừ ông chỉ cần hiểu rồi Có thể ông chưa
làm đến ông thể chưa làm tới ông thiếu
thời gian nó vẫn không chọn cái đấy thì
ra là
tôi không đánh giá cái vụ đấy mà Mấy ông
hiểu được là mình cần phải làm những cái
gì là thành công rồi thì mấy ông đi làm
Nếu không hiểu được cái đấy thì ông
không nào lập trình viên được làm là chỉ
nguyên tốt được ông sẽ chỉ là cô đơn
thôi không phải là điều rapper Pearl
nhìn vào bài toán lại hình dung được
mình cần phải làm cái gì còn cốt đời
đúng kiểu dạng như là thư ký soạn thảo
văn bản Người ta bảo Ông làm cái gì ông
làm được mỗi thế ngọn cũng chỉ biết mỗi
thấy ông không nâng cấp ông không cải
thiện được nó thêm ông ạ Ừ tớ không
hướng về ông như thế
Ờ Ờ
hôm nay lâu không cập nhật nhóm 2 lâu
không cập nhật này nó kệ thôi tiếp theo
nhóm này
Ai Cập nhật homa hôm trước v-app date
vẫn tên là biết à
Ừ đúng tuần trước à
- 11 giờ đêm tuần trước
mình ở tôi chưa xem hộ nhóm máy phân
tích
khi phân tích không thích
dùng cái Linh khác vậy
Vì sao rồi này còn sẽ phân tích nhà đợi
tí nha à
rồi không chơi với nó rồi à
ừ ừ
điểm lạnh Ok nha vẫn là điểm danh không
ạ sinh viên giảng viên giao vụ đúng
không
thôi khóa biểu hai khóa thông báo nữa
hơi khó này phản hồi thông báo luôn ạ
bữa trưa cái này bắt đầu đi hơi xa mấy
cái vụ điểm danh nhà tiếp
Saclo thành sinh viên theo được phân
công nha thì vào điểm danh Ok này thôi
khóa biểu lưu lại không có biểu luôn Ok
lịch học bù quá khó gì có gửi thông báo
sinh viên cái gửi qua mail được thì bây
giờ bảo lưu lại trong đó bay thông báo
Thư với lại lăng nhăng chỉ số ngày nghỉ
theo quy định tuổi ở ngoài làm thuốc ta
đấy Nếu Hạnh Phúc To quá à ba mẹ thì tội
không được
sẽ hỏi câu trả lời phản hồi của sinh
viên của giáo viên Okay chúng ta quá
em mới chỉ Phân tích thôi chứ làm gì cả
nhưng mà đỡ người thuốc tao vậy Em có sợ
điều này à
à à
thứ hai đi tên
Ừ
cái gì đây
Em gửi cái này làm gì
Ok thứ khó biểu môn phòng rồi nhóm này
làm bếp An này tôi sẽ trả hơn tôi chưa
chấm qua cái Ngó mày tôi sẽ sẽ phải họp
riêng nhóm mày chấm Sao không ổn phân
tích linh tinh rồi
a red-letter tay lâu lắm rồi
a cho bổ sung gì cả
ở nhóm
2527 lại trước chưa có gì mấy
i-tác gần đây mất tích rồi nhỏ Ma 5
Có ổn không ạ
anh xóa
a doctor bai Ok xem nào tôi ba nhé
ừ ừ
hồ sơ đồ thực thể
ý tưởng quản lý điểm sinh viên điểm ok
ok sợ mình xem từ xô thể cho nha
cô
giáo vụ ngành anh khoa lớp
không lưu mã không à
phải 1n thằng này thằng này phải lưu lên
mã thằng này chứ
Anh nói sai rồi
Ừ cái này nếu có lỗi như này rõ phải trả
nếu bạn thế này này phải nói thằng em
đúng
ô kê
ở lớp mã khóa mã khóa mã ngành
đấy tự nhiên chui bảo là khóa đấy vậy
em
tự như có khóa đây
e24hvn nhau tại một thằng trung gian
không ạ
muốn mở khóa ok rồi nè
cơ
hội sinh viên như này
quản lý về điểm tôi chưa thấy điểm của
người sinh ra ở đâu luôn ngóng này là
minh tinh rồi sử dụng linh tinh
cách chữa sau
có
lại đang chơi Liên Minh Huyền Thoại này
mình đang chữa thì ông mình đã chữa trị
nhỏ đấy nhưng nhắm được cho lô
a36 gốc chữa đẩy cốt lên ok
rồi Tôi nói chán chê rồi đó tôi không
Tôi không ép mấy ông nó bạ trên tất cả
trên tinh thần tự nguyện và kết hợp được
gọi là thoải mái thôi Bởi vì thực ra là
cái này ở tôi chả được cái gì cả Nói thả
trợ điều đấy anh nha Rồi mày ông á cái
thoải mái Tôi không cần đoàn đấy ông
chơi tội mình còn nghiện game này nhưng
quan trọng là
anh ta ờ
ý với quan điểm đơn giản là điểm là
Vì một khi ở một là không làm hay làm
cho tốt không làm nữa rồi Những đặc biệt
Tôi là một thằng quân tử có dạng mà nói
được là làm được chứ không phải là kiểu
quân tử là nhiều người hiểu nhầm con tử
là con trai thứ đã sai con từ cả nam nữ
đều như nhau nhé là nói phải làm được ai
thực hiện và đã quyết thì phải làm được
đấy
vì vậy tô quan điểm như thế
người mỗi người gà họ họ hãy Họ đang đây
ngay nhỉ má họ thoải mái làm sao tôi
không đánh đồng ý kiến ai cả à
là làm về tôi Em Mất Thôi mất công chấm
thì mấy ông phải mất công an chứ đúng
không Không đi chơi là tối thiểu gì vậy
Ừ ok nhóm này Hôm trước Cập nhật cái kia
a lot in page cái thứ thứ
à Hôm trước cũng cập nhật nhóm này cập
nhật khá nhiều
nhật thì tôi xem lại mấy cái nhóm này
chấm như thế nào quên xử lý rồi
chú Tùng ơi sao gà mái ông tôi không cần
mấy ông chơi bời gì cả tôi là một thằng
chơi bời cho cứ có em à
nhưng mà nó không không nên là kiểu là
hứa suông không phải làm chuông bởi việc
đặc biệt ở đây còn làm theo nhóm thì nó
sẽ còn có cả tinh thần đồng đội nữa do
quan trọng mấy ông chơi game thì mới
vọng sẽ biết được là khi mà anh chơi
game dở mà thoát game là sẽ bị phạt với
nó không tinh thần tập thể từ đồng đội
không ạ thì bây giờ sẽ thế bây giờ mấy
ông làm việc là phải xa làm ngoại ở
chung nhà tôi Hỷ cũng Thực ra tôi khá
khó chịu một vài ông mà chỉ cắm đầu vào
là không biết chơi như con người ở những
con người nhàn chán Tôi không thích
không thích giao lưu với người thật yêu
mà với Mỹ người mà chỉ cắm đầu ở chơi
tội chửi tôi chửi nhiều lắm Mày học sinh
viên rồi mình ạ
em nói chị này Ừ nếu mày à Hôm trước thì
nhờ tôi có chấm nhóm may về tài liệu rồi
ở nhóm này không trước kiểu mỗi tệ gà
được có mỗi Tài liệu nhà bây giờ thêm
cái mày cái trang đăng nhập ngoại cập
nhật thêm một vài cái ha cậu đây có sử
liệu gì đây xem thử xem
Ai Cập nhật cơ sở liệu nghe cứ cậu có
mùi gì
huấn luyện đổi các dữ liệu
à à
ừ ừ
tỉnh làm view và router bằng
ờ ờ ờ view Ổn không anh thao tác là tùy
ý thôi Tôi không cần mấy ông bây giờ áp
dụng bất kỳ công nghệ nào cả bây giờ mấy
ông không làm ra bao à không gặp ai ông
hoàng java for được nhưng mà tôi không
chuyên là cái đấy thì nhất là tôi sẽ khó
chữa trong cái ông hỏi chấm nhưng mà ông
thứ hai đó là là tôi sẽ có cái tôi tôi
anh sẽ cao hơn khi mà ông tôi nhắc cái
đấy bên TP rồi mà ông ấy không làm không
Không sửa cho mấy ông sẽ lấy cờ là à
ngôn ngữ khác là cái gì đó thì chắc chả
Lan thôi đúng không ạ mối quan điểm đó
Kiểu tôi chữa là chữa chung rồi mà Mấy
ông thì mấy ông đã chọn Cái bước định có
đường khác không ạ thì mới ông phải tự
tự giải quyết được cái đấy đúng ạ
anh vào đấy thì quan trọng là mấy ông
hỏi tôi tôi khó giải đáp lực cho mấy ông
thôi
lưu ý là tội biết một tí biết một tí
thôi nhưng mà tội Thực ra cũng khó mà
trả lời cho má
họ tôi biết làm thôi trên công ty cốt mà
à
à à
cơ con người ta bây cập nhật ở trong cơ
sở dữ liệu chứ không phải cập nhật mốt
anh không biết được cửa ông ấy đã cập
nhập cái gì đó xem nhé có bảng lớp này
mệt đấy
anh tư vấn viên à Ok ở
ưu điểm danh á á
tất cả nước
Anh là gì anh kể cho tặng tạm được
có tài liệu rồi
liệu nốt tuần này rồi phải tôi xem lại
hôm trước Và tôi yêu cầu cái đi trước
anh nhờ tôi yêu cầu là hoàn thiện tài
liệu về bản vẽ này làm showed những
người bạn cơ bản này đúng không ạ Nếu
vẫn chưa yêu cầu gặp thì cả tôi tôi bảo
mấy ông à hẹn đến Like là bao nhiêu nhá
là
ở
làng 31 tháng sau là con người ông đúng
nhỉ bảo vậy thử đúng không Đó Sẽ bảo vệ
hình tính năng quan trọng gì gì đó nghĩa
là nếu thế nếu Thế là mình sẽ là 25 này
một tuần nữa này là mùng 2 này chí này
U16 bắt đầu từ ngày 16 đến ngày 16 thì
sẽ
sẽ tôi yêu cầu sẽ nói chung ở Tôi sẽ bắt
đầu chuẩn bị yêu cầu mấy ông làm hẳn
những cái showed những cái bảng quan
trọng những cái tính năng quan trọng
nhất của cái đoán của ông rồi tôi sẽ yêu
cầu mấy cái nhóm đấy à
Anh ở trong làm bằng cách nào đó để mà
chạy thử để tôi xem Để tôi tôi chấm cho
em mình nhóm đấy ổn này chưa Nếu không
gửi tôi không ạ Nếu không thể tạo xít
thế mà để mà tôi kéo có về tôi chạy thử
để một cách hoặc là hoặc là
mì ông nói chung là quay video hay bằng
cách gì đó để mà tôi xem được à thế Mọi
thứ mọi thứ đều có ổn Đúng rồi ngày 30
không mà mười bảo cái thuộc thì ngày 16
lại cũng giữ hàng đi để mà tôi xem mấy
ông á là làm những cái tính năng quan
trọng Đấy nó nó có thực sự là kiểu nó nó
đã đã ngon chưa cần phải sửa cái gì
không hiểu hiểu ý tôi không ạ còn trong
thời gian này chị mếu phải làm showed và
xong xong hết rồi mình như thế
ok nhóm này mới cập nhật lúc 7 giờ
ở đây thêm một loạt rồi
phần méo cũng bận thôi Vợ không trách gì
cả
này nó cũng có một cái gì là thúc mà
không
anh cũng 2020 bị lỗi đâu
ha ha
ở lại cái thường cái biết ý nghĩa tôi
từng sửa nhóm mày vụ không cho cây
thương đến VIP vậy rồi mà nhỉ
bí ngô
hồ sơ đồ ghế xe từng sữa rồi
An mildura đúng rồi à anh ơi
Ừ đúng nhỉ
làm như thế này nhỉ
Anh trông lạ mày Em
nói làm cái giao diện này hơi say rồi
này nhá nhóm này để xem lại đây đây tay
nào ạ
Ừ hình như đề tài nó là
như Tách cái gì đấy tệ ạ
nhóm này là đề tài là về gì nhỉ lịch sử
với đề tài nhóm này
ở nhóm A
37 đúng không ạ
à à
là ở bên phía người dùng là tìm xe đúng
không
đi
tìm thay đồ
khi người dùng tìm thấy đầu ở đây bên
anh đúng không người dùng Tìm chuyến xe
ok rồi hôm trước là vụ này ổn rồi này
xong nhận trường xe Ok hôm trước nói Qua
vụ này có vẻ ổn rồi này thấy hình lấy sự
giao diện Bên nào đây nói cho một cái
này ổn nó lại Ok để bên người dùng hoa
tiếp Thế nào là để tìm hiểu bến amin
benehmen Lúc đầu thì mày ông hình dung
đấy thì bây giờ hình dung nó ra mình có
rất nhiều xe ở ngoạn mình sẽ phải thứ
nhất là ngập đầu khóa xe lấy thôi rẽ thứ
2 là nó có theo chuyến 200 ạ Nó có cố
định hay mọi thứ các thử thứ không để để
lấy hình dung của bài toán nhập có dễ
không ạ Đây thì
Ừ thì mình sẽ làm gì sao ngọn cái sơ đồ
cơ sở dữ liệu rồi nhỉ
sẵn danh sách xe này
Anh quay lắm bằng đi
đây đây Thôi bỏ qua mày cái này nhé
Em lại bắt đầu đi hơi xa vấn đề rồi
có gì con cá vận chuyển hàng hóa tập lái
xe tự nhiên đời vẫn trường hàng hóa đây
Bỏ bỏ bột từ chắc chắn tôi không diệt
cái luôn
được như vậy thôi Quan trọng gì không
gì rồi cơ mà vẫn có muốn có này đi theo
đi theo có đi theo cơ thể đỡ thực thể
nào thể đi theo
đây cũng say rồi không có cái này sai
rồi có số đầu ghế hành ông ông sữa chỗ
nào rồi
qua Chả liên quan đến tính năng này bầu
cua vận chuyển hàng hóa
hoàn về thì sao thì sao Mình còn chẳng
đạt được vào lại trả tiền qua Online đó
hôn vẽ
đây đấy thanh toán online của bà luôn
đấy à
ừ ừ
ở đây hình dung nhá giáo sư của là Hồi
đấy tôi nhớ tôi phân tích cho nhóm này
thì phải bao kiểu chuyến xe nó cố định
đúng không Thì mình sẽ mình sẽ phải lưu
lại cái đầu tiên là lưu lại các chuyến
đã đúng không sau đó thì mình nói chung
mình tạo ra mình có một cái sơ đồ này
nhất là Sơ đồ tạo ra tuyên chuyến xe nó
sẽ có điểm đi điểm đến đúng không đấy
tôi về tôi không Tôi thấy đỡ mấy bạn đã
sai rồi em tôi không biết cách chứ kể
Nói chung là có những cái phone nào để
điên nữa Nhầm cái đôi cái chắc chắn có
nó sẽ điểm đi điểm đến và khung giờ trả
lại nó sẽ cho chọn nhiều khung giờ giả
sử Giả sử nhé nếu như tôi đang hình dung
thì có để làm đơn giản thì cậu này là sự
là cho một cái bến xe là một cái bến xe
có tầm 20 xe xong rồi à xe đấy sẽ có
lịch đi cố định hàng ngày từ mấy giờ đến
mấy giờ cả đi cà phê chẳng hạn thế Thì
ví dụ từ đáy giờ em đi từ Hà Nội đến Hải
Phòng rồi nhá có những giờ cố định ở như
thế nào Sau mỗi giờ về sẽ như thế nào và
Vần đấy thì thì mình sẽ lưu lại điểm đi
điểm đến và khung giờ cố định của từng
là đấy và ngược lại luôn cả nó hay chiều
mà nó sẽ ngược lại luôn đó sau đó thì
mình sẽ gán mình sẽ thêm những lời xe
mình sẽ thêm mình sẽ có pho mà thêm
những cái xe cho những cái chuyến truyền
đấy Đấy
sau đó thì về sau giao diện của ấn mình
sẽ hiển thị ra là là chuyến truyền đi
hàng ngày này thì nó có bao nhiêu khách
vẫn Vân nói chung cái đấy tính sau đấy à
anh nói chung là về cái đặt vé
Mở bài gì à amin vẫn phải duyệt cả về
nữa ta thử nữa không ạ
à Nhưng cái đấy à Em có cái trường hợp
khác nữa Nhưng mà cái đầu tiên các bạn
này cần vẽ đó là vẽ được cái sơ đồ này
thêm chuyến xe mà thêm xe thêm xe thì đó
thì tạm bỏ qua về ghế vip thì cái thường
đi như hôm trước tôi có nó vụ đấy bỏ qua
vực đấy Đã mấy ông đừng nghĩ phức tạp
mọi người không làm xe trộn giá giá khác
nhau thế là được rồi ngồi nghĩ ngồi nghĩ
về cái lưu lại cả sơ đồ ghế cơ thì có
lằng nhằng nữa bỏ qua mấy vụ này đi
không làm tận hai mấy bạn ấy nhá ông là
Mười bả còn chưa Nay bạn
ông chết luôn ở trong giai đoạn trứng
nước chứ không cần kiểu ghim nữa ừ
a tiếp theo nhóm này người mất tích rồi
à
ừ sáng mai lấy cho tôi ta mất tích hết
rồi làm 8 mất tích rồi Okay tiếp 59 ờ
Ai Cập nhật 14 9 mức trước à
ở
hạt mà ông đồ rồi à
à à em
giờ được ghi chấm chấm ở trong cái
tài liệu tài liệu này nó như cuốn sách
này mấy ông đi lại không chấm Nếu phải
căn chỉnh mình cái này tao chúng về sau
tôi sẽ sửa với cái thay đổi sau
đấy
Ừ tự nhiên quay lại bán hàng này à
anh ngắm hai trường bán hàng nó rẽ nhầm
số mấy
Ồ thông số 9 cho bán hàng này
nó tự nhìn nhảy lại bán hàng này
nhóm nhóm này tự nhiên nhảy bán hàng đây
không hiểu à
Anh không muốn em đâu 59 Hôm trước mình
chỉ có tài liệu
luôn á
à à
ở đâu có thể cập nhật được làm ta ăn cơm
chưa
ừ ừ
reply cancel
A Z
à à
nhưng mà để nhằm không xịn
ừ ừ
em ở đâu
các em ạ
Bộ Quốc phòng giao diện rồi đâu tài liệu
đây Ok không phải giao diện rồi đăng ký
đăng ký đây là
ở đây là về gì nhỉ Đây là về
trung tâm thi bằng lái ôtô Ok Ok nghĩa
là sẽ có
có chứng minh thư phải ngày tháng năm
sinh Ok Rồi
để tạo được
nhờ đăng kí ở ở trong máy Ôi Thực ra rìa
ra thì mình sẽ phải là mình cho chọn
Trước mình cho chọn trước cái khóa Thôi
thì ta khó ở đây nhưng chồng sẽ ổn hơn
Ừ mình lên mình xem quá các thứ thứ rồi
mình đăng ký chứ phải hiển thị sẵn thì
con đăng ký thế anh sẽ tìm đã
Ừ cái gì vậy
Ừ ông là tr Screen bar Screen như lại
tội chẳng hiểu đối với spin nào rồi tự
đoán đúng không Thêm học viên à
Vietnamese
ô
nghe gọi điện cho người ta để mà anh ấy
đã sẽ gọi điện cho mình mình làm à à
thì tại sao học viên cần có mật khẩu mật
khẩu người dùng cần đăng nhập vào trang
mình điểm gì nhỉ à
em không nhớ cái vụ người dùng cần đăng
nhập vào trang này luôn đấy người dùng
Đăng nhập vào trang này điểm đi hẹn Cần
mật khẩu rồi đấy ạ
nếu có người ta gọi cho ông thì càng
không cần cho ông Điền mật khẩu mật khẩu
sẽ đến để mặc thích
rồi tự động gửi hoặc mật khẩu để ngẫu
nhiên rồi gửi qua mail Người Ta Tốt nhất
là đấy Không nói chung là Giả sử có Điền
Mail thôi thường tôi bảo đăng ký đăng ký
bằng lái thì cần gì phải nhập những cái
thông tin lằng nhằng ngay nó ít thông
tin thôi đấy
Tiệp chi tiết Lương
Cái này không phải là một cái tính năng
số tính năng quan trọng lắm nhưng mà họ
được người ta sẽ nhập ở
thì nhập cái chi tiết Lương này nó
thôi Hiển thị thông tin thời gian số
buồn rồi nhập lương đúng không Chị sẽ
lại cũng được cũng được thêm vào việc
ông ấy bị ngược lôgic thế này anh chưa
thấy kia được
Nhược thấy không kiểu như ý tưởng thì
ông cái gì trước
bảng diệt lương á á
em về mấy cái tính năng nâng cao hơn thế
này tôi sẽ tôi sẽ phải diệt của ông sau
cái này tôi khó mà thể hình dung được
toàn bộ những cái tính năng trước của
mèo như thế này tôi sẽ nói qua trước và
là nhất là những cái tính năng đầu tiên
mà ông cần phải làm bằng tính năng giờ
sự đăng ký này chắc chắn đấy Mình không
cần phải làm này tiếp theo thêm giáo
viên thì ok này con về lương thì thì cái
đấy lại là cái sau người mà ông Nếu
không thể bổ sung sau ở tôi sẽ chữa sau
chờ để nói cái này tôi cũng không hình
dung được tôi chưa hình dung được bài
toán trong đầu lại thực sự là nhóm của
mấy ông cần cái gì
nhưng ông cứ qua người được nhưng mà
nhưng mà thế này Thực ra nếu mà ông
Trịnh hiển thị cái cái bạc chung chung
như này thì ra hơi khó rồi mà quản lý
kiểm soát nói thật đấy rất khó quản lý
kiểm Pháp ông hiển thị ra bầu 30 giáo
viên thôi Cái gì mũi tên thời gian là Lư
cho người dùng nó sẽ bị làm sao đó người
dùng sẽ không làm cái quần được
ở đây tôi sẽ dạy mày ông về cách để mà
tính lương sau thật mà ông sẽ phải sửa
cái này tôi sẽ tôi
Chị tôi ơi chẳng lẽ cho mày ông xem qua
về cái ạ Cái
đi
thử thứ tối hãy cho mình không xem qua
luôn vềcách điểm chấm công có tính lương
như thế nào Tôi cho ông xem à
à à
ừ ừ
bây giờ thì đợi tí
Vì
sao giờ không truy cập được
Ông nói cốt là hồi trước tôi làm ở vụ
tình lương rồi
không sao không sao tội cho mình muốn
xem cái từng lương là sẽ hợp lý như nào
sẽ chọn tháng chọn năm rồi thì bị ra một
người quyết định lương người đấy chứ
không phải là kiểu như của mấy ông đang
làm đâu
Ê
cho xem
trang web quản lý hạ thế cho mấy ông xem
cái trang web quản lý theo từng làm thì
nó sẽ kỳ công như thế nào Giờ kỳ công
luôn
Hơi bị khoe với tím nhưng mà còn chung
rồi đấy tự tôi làm Và cũng kia ông nghĩ
ông người dùng cũng làm các hướng thứ để
tiện người rồi nó sẽ chọn khám chọn năm
chồng rồi thì ra tất cả các giáo viên
trong buổi trong tháng đấy có dậy sau đó
thì hiển thị chọn thêm giáo viên nữa thì
mới hiển thị ra các tướng buổi sao mình
sẽ rét xét duyệt từng buổi đấy đấy để
cho Nói chung là ôn chứ không phải hiển
thị ra kiểu dạng là cái bạc chung chung
như này người dùng rất khó duyệt một cái
gì đó ngoại khi ông nhìn người mình
không việc gì Dựa theo tên này rồi đoán
này đàn xem và nó dậy này đúng hay không
à Thế như nào Cái này rất khó làm ở liền
một người nào đó thật
em nấu hiểu cho không làm cái đấy được
không được
tí mèo nhóm 9 đồng chí nữa rồi bảo là
ê buốt vấn đề đúng không Kệ nha
a89 một số người đi ở nhà
ở trang chủ giao diện các thử Ok
tại sao của Bưu đây này
ở nhóm này làm về cái gì nhỉ
cho thuê
cho thuê xe
mua thuê xe tự lái đúng không ạ
các tính năng
ở
acet tấm ờ ờ
Có ai còn thiếu cái này khi mà thêm thì
mới hàng ngoại thật vui nó sẽ kiểu sẽ về
bản chất là đây là không phải thêm thích
hàng mình sẽ không dùng trong trường hợp
này mình không phải thêm khách hàng mà
mình sẽ là mình sẽ là ở tạ à Gần nhà tạo
hóa đơn và tạo à Rồi chúng tạo hợp đồng
để thuê một xe nào đó sẽ bao gồm cả chọn
xe đấy Ông không hình dung được bài toán
này cho lắm khi mà ăn Min vào các trang
web của ông không phải mỗi thêm khách
hàng thủ công như này không Không có
chuyện đấy mà sẽ là sao mình sẽ là chọn
xe chọn xe đã phải từng bước từng bước
đã chọn xe này thôi Sau đó thì
ý là chọn thời gian thời gian hiểu thời
gian bắt đầu thuê đến thời gian kết thúc
thuê là bạn đấy tôi trị giá tiền có
những thứ đó chọn các hơi nữa sau sau đó
thì ấn OK thì sẽ nhảy ra cái foam để mà
thêm khách hàng nhanh như thế này khi mà
điền cái này thì nó sẽ tự động điên số
điện thoại nên để đến trước và khi điền
số điện thoại nó sẽ đề xuất ra những cái
khách hàng mà đã thuê rồi theo trục theo
số điện thoại đấy để mà Mình gợi ý ra
đều mình có thể đỡ phải điền toàn bộ
đồng này và sẽ tự động điền hộ mình rồi
ạ không ngu ra nêm với bắt muốn ở đây
mày heo ngày cứ bị hình dung trang đạo
cần đăng nhập Vậy mấy trang này người ta
đến trực tiếp Người ta làm không đăng
nhập sẽ đặt của có thể liên hệ ông qua
mạng của trực tiếp đến làm việc với ông
ngọn không có đăng nhập lấy cả à ở đó
sau đó đi Khi mà điện khi mà có thông
tin các thứ thử điện xong hết rồi không
ạ thì thì ấn tạo hợp đồng sau đó sẽ hiển
thị ra cái pho mình thì sửa cả hợp đồng
để nữa do sự thế Tại nói cho mình sẽ
vượt qua cái form sữa hợp đồng đấy rồi
mình ăn nốt tin đấy toàn bộ tất cả bước
là như thế
ii-chương vải là thêm sửa soạn như thế
này nếu hiểu rồi em sợ nghe không nghĩ
gì cả
À thế à tôi đâu bắt mấy ông phải
phải ngồi vẽ cái này làm gì vậy Cái này
em mới không chỉ ngồi nghĩ là vẽ ra đúng
cái đã ta bây có bao nhiêu cột thì ông
sẽ vẽ bấy nhiêu cái phone này mà điện á
nó không nghĩa gì cả đúng không
không không cần có chung cái mà tôi muốn
nói nó từng bước từng bước của Amin là
này mày ông ấy 1 2 3 4 như thế Không
quan tâm mấy ông là mấy cái này lỡ luôn
đấy ông ạ thì do mày đón không mấy ông
hình dung được cả khách hàng vào làm
những cái gì từ đầu đến cuối không amin
vào làm từ gì từ đầu tiên của ông đấy
sau đó đi từng bước từng bước họ sẽ nhìn
thấy những cái phone nào Phòng nào Phòng
nào chưa đấy thì hình dung không
Ừ Thì đấy là một cái quá trình khép kín
một cái gọi gọi là một cái một cái giao
dịch cứ cho một dùng từ giao dịch 1 trên
sân nó ngoác một cái quá trình khép kín
từ đầu đến cuối nó sẽ diễn biến là như
thế nào thì cũng phải làm được cái xong
rồi đấy những cái phom của cái đấy Nó là
một cái ổn ngoại nhập vào như nào rồi in
ra như nào Ngoại
tìm kiếm Chọn khu vực ngày bắt đầu kết
thúc này quá ít quá ít luôn ông phải
chọn xe nữa giả sử Khách hàng chọn xe
nữa hướng rồi thì đã đến số xe Cá thứ
đầy ngoạn thôi có thể chọn loại xe mới
sẽ cũ tầm giá tiền bao nhiêu Vân kiểu
này thì nó đơn giản quá
hai nhóm chính nhóm
9 vừa nó có tận hai ông đang còn đây mà
đúng không
ừ ừ Ê mày ông thấy tôi vừa góp ý
muốn chơi game 1
này nhá Mấy ông tôi bảo mấy ông thợ chế
Mất 34 tuần thì ngồi vẽ con thôi nhờ mua
khi phong chuẩn nên đúng không Nhưng Cốt
nó sẽ nhàn hơn mà mày cũng sẽ hiểu được
tư duy của bài toán ông ạ nói chung và
gần như ở cả một cái đồ án mấy ông làm
đúng cái phòng chuẩn và ông Nam được
song với tính năng đây là thành công rồi
Gần như hàng công bởi vì ra cái cái đồ
án của ông quan trọng nhất là tính năng
đấy nhớ là sự tính năng đấy mà không làm
form với ba lần ông cháu có ông chỉ là
ông nhập địa vào lúc ạ Thì đấy vẫn là
một cái phần mềm với đi gọi không quan
tâm giao diện đâu nhà mày nha Không Quan
Tâm ông đã làm được bao nhiêu tính năng
nhưng ở Việt Nam quan trọng nhất của cái
đoạn của ông ông làm không không hiểu
được người dùng thì nó là cái phần mềm
cứ đi thật mặc kệ phần mềm mong ăn tiền
nhất là các phần mình là cái tính năng
mấy mà nó không có làm việc gì không vẽ
vẽ đi vậy lại form áo chuẩn nữa tôi
Anh hiểu chứ
à à
ờ ờ
khi
trước đây bảo vệ vừa trước của mỗi vuốt
thôi
ông đấy thêm ông chưa đẩy lên men rồi
có mỗi cái wed say rồi thôi
ừ ừ
anh Mạnh tôi anh sĩ này rồi không có tự
tìm anh ơi chị ạ
251 phòng giao diện một phút trước
mấy khi hết của trái phép like trường à
Ai Cập nhật một phút trước ạ ạ
Ơ hay
cho đến lần nhóm mình rồi nhanh nhanh
nhanh
em mấy giờ
mô phỏng giao diện đâu
mắt
có mí để mô phỏng diện nhưng mà phải để
lên thì là router-view và controller Ông
bịt tôi
Khi nào mày đẩy lắm đấy Ôi để ép mua
phòng lao diệt để hết bao nhiêu cốt đầy
đủ cốt ca sister để gì đây A
em ngồi thế này không đi làm đâu
điểm đi làm rồi ngày chửi ấy kiểu con
nít nhớ có mí về sao đi để tiếng Anh
không nên việc này thứ nhất với ai đó
không có con nít kiểu Dạ con bị đẩy hết
một đống lên kiểu khi con gì Chú thích
kiểu cho có ai nhá chết
à Xong rồi bởi vì sao tại sao tự nhiên
tôi Nhắc nhiều vụ đấy bởi vì nó khái
niệm reverse con nít Thế làm gì à thể sử
cãi của ông có vấn đề và nó nghĩ rằng ạ
nó nghĩ là kiểu cái đấy nhìn thêm mỗi
cái mô tả thêm mô phỏng ấy Thực ra nó
hoàn toàn của chữ vives như này nó sẽ
khôi phục lại cái cũ có ngày mai hết cốt
của mì ông thật đấy nghe mày ông sẽ ghi
rất chi tiết nó liên quan thì những phần
nào để cho người ta chỗ sẽ cân nhắc khi
mở vì mất là gì đó không biết đã nhìn
kiểu cập nhật mỗi giao diện không phải
ra sự người ta thấy đang cốt vấn đề xảy
ra đi Vứt cái tự những chết mất hết bao
nhiêu thứ ngoại không chơi kiểu này
nhiều nha
đẩy lên đúng không Đấy là 100 Cái lỗi
của ông không ạ làm đồ án này tôi đang
hướng đến cho mấy ông mục đích của đồ án
này là gì là để ra ông sẽ là Junio ý
nhất là như thế ít nhất là Yugi Oh chúng
phải Face Bây giờ thì không biết gì hôm
nay tờ Ok chấp nhận chuyện yêu là in ra
nó phải biết cách cậu đẩy cốt các thử
làm việc theo nhóm Vân cốt chưa đủ vẫn
bằng suliot thôi và chưa có kinh nghiệm
bằng siro thôi Còn tất cả những cái mà
mà gọi là làm việc theo nhóm này xong
ngồi xử lý hình dung bài toán các từ thứ
phải nắm được không ạ
có phải nắm được chứ không thì không để
tôi cần để tốn công là cho ông làm đâu
bán làm gì không ạ
ai cho mà ông Quen Nhí làm gì mày cũng
để hết loài cho nhanh mình ạ nếu không
làm việc theo ý kiểu nhà em cũng để in
writing Anh xài nghĩa gì cả đúng không
Anh hiểu chứ
giao diện admin ra diện đỗ xanh không
Tôi không biết nhận mình cái giao diện
này nhá Nó diện để để em đấy trái nghĩa
gì anh khóc nộp cho có ai chết rồi
Rồi bên này Ha cái này cái gì đây
số trang index
đi học không cần tránh gì đấy
anh không cần giao diện amin luôn sinh
viên hôm không cần
Ở trang này là cái gì bắt đầu không hình
dung ở bên trang web của ông này là cái
đồ án về cái gì đấy
vậy
ở
nhiều tính năng rất nhiều tính năng nữa
đi vào máy ông chỉ có một cái này rồi
thế này làm xong với ông biết được cần
phải cốt thì thì em có không hình dung
được Còn mấy ông có những tính năng là
quan trọng với ông sao có được
em có thêm sửa xóa tất cả bà hả
ha ha ha
thích sao cho cho mấy ông ấy hiểu nữa
buồn khóc khóc nữa à
nói mất tích rồi à
khi sex
Nguyễn Khang vui không khi mà tôi bài ca
mang nhóm khác cha vui mà không
anh ấy trừ mình ra vui mật
anh không có
Anh
quay chỉ làm cốc à ở đây nó bắt đúng
không ở đây ok à
Ừ thôi tôi chấm cốt nha thôi chẳng có
nhiều tội nó chưa chấm Cốt
ừ ừ
em sợ đi
Thôi con dậy lại chán sinh viên ở trên
trường cần nhà vãi nhờ nỗi buồn đây Chọn
sân này ngập đến sân này tìm kiếm Ôi
nhìn chị ra Cá thứ Ok
thì chi tiết sân này giá này
tất cả Thử là sân theo cách khối số
cũng được đúng cũng đúng không ra số này
Số gì Anh nói sao không không không thì
để bộ không nên ghi số điện thoại thật
mình nhá Gọi đi số trúng trúng nói tên
là sống chung hạn chế kêu để tên logo gì
đó đụng chạm thật đấy tiết đặt trực
tuyến nút đã trực tuyến nó sẽ dành đấy
đi sáng nay đúng không Ok Đấy đấy mà ông
thấy Yoo ri kiểu đấy vậy ổn không sang
điện các thứ nho nhập Hữu thế xài mất
rồi Cái này cũng đặt sân này ông đặt bao
lâu
thiếu rồi ông đã bao lâu
U23 Motul
khi thiếu rồi
mới thấy cái này thiếu đó là ông chưa có
chọn thời gian này thời gian giờ để biết
là sân nào đánh trống hay không hiểu chứ
Ừ Thế làm sao biết được Sân nào ăn chống
ông đặt cái mua hẳn luôn à đúng không
Đấy chưa hình dung được bài toán thôi nó
phải là chọn theo thời gian trôi đi ra
sân trống sau đó thì ông sẽ đặt theo vậy
đặt trong khung giờ nào đó vân vẫn là sự
giả sự là bên mình chưa làm thanh toán
online nhưng mà cứ giả đặt cái có những
người khác không đạt được trong khung
giờ đấy thì nói như thế nào ạ Đấy ngày
không hiểu gì cho ông thì nó sẽ bao gồm
và chọn thời gian đấy chứ ạ Chứ mày ông
làm như thế này Gì à là mua hẳn sân nhà
người ta rồi đúng không
có chọn khung giờ có chậm ngày không mua
thảm luôn
Anh đàm vĩnh viễn luôn nghỉ không
chỉ có thế này thôi Chẳng có gì cả ngoại
trừ nghị luôn số sẵn ở đây càng tốt này
thêm sân nhanh nghe ngồi được
có thêm nhưng mà để hiển thị thêm săn
được hơi sai chỗ khu vực để thêm khu vực
đúng ạ Okay tiếp điều à
Khi dịch Huy nếu mà Hiển thị như thế này
đấy Hơi sai hơi chiếu thông tin
Ừ ừ cũng hiểu điện thời gian nhận thời
gian chạm tốt với chả liên hoàn máy bay
đó ông ấy nhớ lại ông thêm vào nhưng mà
cái này thì ông ông không xem chi tiết
luôn à
trộn xem có vẻ hợp lý không Ừ phải hợp
lý nhớ không biết là số nào nhớ nghe có
vẻ hợp lý chưa Thôi ạ Ta Đây đúng kiểu
hết giờ chả có thông tin về số điện
thoại đẹp không ạ
Không có gì cả
du lịch sử Việt cũng chẳng có bản lĩnh
thông tin gì cả đúng không cái này thì
ra có thể vẽ sau cái này là tính năng bố
cái tính năng này tính năng phải về sau
mình động đến thì mình mới nghĩ là cái
vẽ thì ok Bỏ qua những tính năng ra
những tính năng mà mình cần làm đầu hết
thì cần phải nghĩ trước mình vẽ trước Ok
như cái đây chú trả lời mày ông thấy cái
này vừa sai đúng ạ Chả giải quyết hơn để
gây Cả
thêm sân thêm sân như này lại một cái
sai có phải thì ở khu vực trước giống
như vừa nãy nói hiển thị khu vực trước
sau ở Mỹ thì ở các sân trong khu vực đấy
con mình thêm sân và trong khu vực đáy
Nó sẽ ổn hơn nhiều cậu ở hiện điều tất
cả sân như này đúng nhưng mà vẫn có một
cái trang để rất là sân nhưng mà chẳng
lời sẵn khác hoặc à mặc định là ông sẽ
tìm kiếm ở trên này sao rồi hiển thị ra
tất cả khu vực cũng được không sao bạn
nhưng mà mình nên ưu tiên là quản lý
theo khu vực hơn là hiển thị ra cậu bây
giờ cũng giận mười mấy cái sân không
hiển thị hết là không khai Ừ nó khó quản
lý ở
ta thêm xuân chọn giá tự sướng loại sân
có những thứ thì riêng với các loại sân
nữa còn lằng nhằng nữa riêng các loại
sân còn làm gì nữa nếu mà ông chị thêm
thủ công rồi ngay có gì À như tôi hồi
trước tôi biết được mấy ông là hình như
là ông tôi không Tôi không bọc đã nên
tôi không nắm rõ vụ này lắm nhé nhưng mà
tôi nhớ là mày ông bà sân to sẽ bằng bốn
chân bé ghép lại gì đó nữa đúng không
các bạn Đấy nó tôi nhớ là tôi chữa cho
nhóm này là sân mình sẽ thêm à
dễ thêm với sơn to sau đó thì nó sẽ tự
sinh ra mày cái sân bé đúng xinh ăn bún
này sân bé và cách lập tên nó sẽ như nào
chán thế đấy em ơi ông phải ngồi nghĩ về
việc này nữa tôi chỉ ông gợi ý thôi rồi
nếu bé Ông này khó quá vậy hỏi tôi sao
ok chưa phân quyền đã bỏ qua bộ phim
Quyền đi Thôi bỏ qua đi đừng có đi xa
bài toàn bài toán của ông nó còn chưa
giải quyết được đâu Đừng nó nhảy cái
khác
Chị ơi con nhóm nào mà cần chấm với cái
vụ vẽ vời xa nào nhỉ
em chưa đúng không Đây nhá hình dung ah
sân Nếu mà chọn sân 70 sao chọn sân 11
thì ông sẽ chỉ ra đây đã
không thì ông mở ngoặc luôn đây là sẽ tự
động tại 4 sân con được hạn theo gia sự
Huế ra sự thể bà sẽ đặt tên nó sẽ là ví
dụ là khu vực tệ ví dụ tên sân là như
này đúng không
thì nó sẽ là cả
Ê bà cái sân này nó sẽ tự động tên Ví dụ
ở lại được nhắn sân
em gà mấy cái sân này thật ra không cần
tên đâu nói thật chẳng nhớ cái tên rồi à
thực là nó theo cái số tự đấy mày không
hiểu Nó sẽ là ví dụ là sự là à Một này
sau đó thì nó sẽ là hai ba bốn ngày ngâm
một là sự sân to nhé 2 3 4 5 nó sẽ sân
nhỏ của Xuân một đấy Chẳng hạn đấy Chả
hạn đấy Ô tôi tôi Thực ra tôi bảo lỗi
chưa đi đá bóng để mà để mà cậu nắm chắc
với cái vụ đấy lắm nhưng tôi khẳng định
Tôi nghĩ không hẳn người ta không nhớ
được tên của một cái sân lô nó sẽ thương
ấy có một khu vực 1 cái khu ở một cái số
thứ tự nó thôi ông thể đến trực tiếp để
người hỏi hỏi người ta xem à Em đặt chân
ở bên kia rồi anh đặt tên nó như thế nào
đánh số hãng như nào đấy Nếu phải đi
khảo sát đấy chứ
anh đúng không khảo sát thì thế mày
không trả thì mấy ông Cư
thì tự thấy cái ý tưởng đó chị không
chục like thôi Kiểu thấy có vẻ là ngon
Năm Ông làm tôi chả khảo sát rồi buồn
quá
khi thở ra đi nha ra rồi về mấy ông làm
bei đúng nghĩa đi bia là đi khảo sát thị
trưởng một phân tích sâu hồi sinh ra
mình cần phải làm những gì
ra ngon ơ
em ngồi mất tích rồi
kê nhà mới mất tích rồi
à à
Ai Cập nhật menu cổ ok
xem thêm khung chương trình
từ khóa kì kì luôn à
nhà mình có nhớ mình giật kỳ của nhóm
nào nhỉ có kỳ ấy rồi
cảm thấy hình chưa mấy ông đang ngồi sửa
đã lại đó bây
không ổn ở đây
có kỳ ấy nhỉ
U19
I dic really like your wikia
đúng không
khóa mà
ở đây mở khóa
ạ Bây giờ là ngành mà
ở đây là
khóa chứ đừng
3 năm bắt đầu năm kết thúc năm học mà
tôi là người cực kì đấy nhỉ Ông anh nghĩ
đâu là cái kì vậy em một kiểu phân tích
một kiểu nhưng mẹ mua cửa
cũ kỹ ở đây không chương trình không như
trình này không sẽ lưu ở đâu
ở đây à
khi xu Master đây là kỳ họp của Quốc
từ
khóa Kỳ
ở nhóm này đồ ăn với cái gì nha quản lý
đĩa mày đi thôi bỏ qua kỳ bỏ Kỳ Hoa Kỳ
nó sẽ chỉ đơn giản là là chương trình
đào tạo với học môn nào thôi nghĩ phức
tạp kì kì cái gì trái nghĩa gì ơi
ăn kỳ khó là Đấy biết ngay mà bên kia
đấy ờ ờ
thêm nhóm học sinh
thế giới thiệu sinh viên trong khóa nào
á
có thêm sinh viên nhanh quản lý bia chọn
môn chọn
áo kiểu thi hiểu không
họ lập Fire
thị cho toàn bộ xong rồi cho điên cũng
được ok ok tao tí
a tiếp theo
đắp Trinh điên à
ờ ờ
đây là môn à à Không để kì đấy của ông
ấy đấy Đây là key được không cũng được
từ khóa
kia
làm thủ môn này xong rồi Như này như thế
này Thống kê đúng không xịn
gà trống xịn đấy
Ừ nhưng mà đây là cho A cho từng sinh
viên à à
thì ra mấy ông đi chị mấy ông gạo đi học
điều mà rồi vì mày cái này mày không thể
lấy giao diện từ Mấy trang khác có bên
này tôi thấy giống bên FPT lắm à à
ở những chị nghỉ làm xịn tiếng Anh các
thứ thứ ở
ừ ừ
Em đang học à Đấy ông ấy chơi theo kì
biết được đạp học hay không Ok rồi năm
học
I năm học ở đâu nhỉ A5 học vừa nãy có
đúng không Rồi ngay sau sinh viên thi
lại chọn khóa chọn kì ra sinh viên thì
lại chê ổn thôi ông lại sang nghĩ việc
tổng kết điểm được ạ Mấy mấy cái ở dưới
tôi sẽ tính sau anh tạm thời có vẻ ổn ạ
Thấy ông mày thống kê hôm trước tôi bảo
khó ổn Đấy từ việc cả nhập vào như nào
xong rồi xong ngồi giữa Nam mình như nào
rồi Cuối năm như thế nào Nếu thấy hợp lý
luôn thích đâu đấy Đấy phải đúng kiểu
pho mát rồi này chắc chắn là bạn này
từng tham khảo ở cái khác rồi bạn lấy
hình dung được bài toán mà cái này nó
cũng dễ Đúng rồi khoa giống trường FPT
ra giống trường FPT nhưng mà Đấy nghĩa
là mấy ông tiếp xúc rồi mày không phân
tích lại thì ra nó cũng
cũng gọi là mình không cần phải suy nghĩ
gì đó nhiều lắm nữa Nhờ mấy ông cũng
phải hình dung được và cần phải làm
những cái gì cũng cũng không đến nỗi
không ạ ở nhóm 20 chưa cập nhật
nhật trong vòng
3 phút ông cập nhận bốn đứa con nít cũng
được đến các hướng thứ cũng không sao ok
nhờ ghi tự update thể chung chung quá
chẳng vào đấy Cái gì Thì rõ là hợp lý
hơn là sự dạng như trong hôm nay không ạ
ok
khi đàn ông có thể gộp lại chung trong
một cái tính năng gì đó thì ổn
chủ nhà
xe Honda Đặt lịch hẹn tình yêu nhỏ mà
tôi trượt rồi
nhà mày có gì rồi tao bỏ qua trong 21
cập nhật 8 giờ lớp trưởng mà Anh tập 18
l 21 phút sớm chán
ở nhóm 21 thì ở cũng có tài liệu hôm
trước rồi phải
em ngủ ngon
rồi chưa chưa chấm vội chậm Mấy cái tài
liệu trước đã
có 522
bộ phim trước mục đích nhằm hay mất tích
rồi
nó hay mất tích rồi ở đâu
còn đang update cái tin mới sao
à à
ở
chưa có gì cả
cập nhật hôm trước do lao Ok trong
viên không Tại sao có mỗi cái đơn giản
này à
300 000
năm quản lý sinh viên nó rất nhiều tính
năng mà
ở mỗi hiển thị ra ông làm cho có rồi
không khóm tôi không về đâu nhé á
em tính tinh
300 quản lý sinh viên thì đâu nhở sẽ sẽ
nhờ quản lý sinh viên à Tại sao tuổi cho
nhóm này làm cái đơn giản đi nha
cô sinh viên đi làm thêm sinh viên có
cái gì đâu nhỉ
anh hả
a cho hình dung được nhóm mày sẽ làm cái
trang web nó có những tính năng gì để
xem à à
Ở sinh vật lý sinh viên tính năng nghỉ ở
dưới dạng thắc mắc không hiểu nhóm chọn
đôi giày lại mình sẽ có những năng gì
đấy
Bây giờ
AE
nhập sinh viên rồi thôi Ngắm sinh chưa
năng đối tượng sắp xếp lịch học
Ô thế Mình trình không sắp xếp lịch học
ưu điểm danh quản lý sinh viên như vậy
Ôm tại điểm danh thôi lịch rằm vậy như
này kết quả học tập kết quả học tập theo
cái gì nhỉ Có anh nhập vào kết quả học
tập đâu mà xem kết quả học tập hả Nhập
xem điều gì nhỉ
vẽ ra chẳng có ai lấy thêm thêm một kết
quả học tập cả nhưng mà
ở đâu có tận 5 đối tượng sử dụng luôn
trưởng khoa phòng đào tạo Quản trị viên
rồi cùng thì ông ấy vẽ hai cái lao như
thế này ông đồ rồi à
ha ha
anh tệ thế này là tệ đấy
Vì thế tôi không về đâu cho tao tôi cũng
Việt kiều này em ạ
thế hả Vui Vẻ tập 5 đối tượng sử dụng
này rồi ông 1,2 cái là heo thiệt sinh
diệt là thầy giáo viên như thế này không
không không không chấp nhận được à
anh bảo ông có ngồi chọn nếu cứ chọn đề
tài khó đi thôi nghĩ ngồi nghĩ mình đang
khó đi xong rồi Tôi ngồi bắt bẻ tấn cái
Mua cho ông ạ Ông ấy nói từng cái mua
cho em béo lại thấy cứ ai à
The
Beatles The clouds I asked
thêm một phòng ở diện từ trước cho xem
nhóm này tôi diệt hà hà tài liệu tôi yên
tôi
Cậu chẳng biết sự trợ tài liệu chưa Từ
cập nhật từ hôm mà
U18 đúng 1 tuần trước
cách tạo trạm giờ à
ở số nhà sức chứa Thì nhờ tôi chứng chữa
nhóm mai rồi Ổn rồi tạm tạm ổn rồi
2 năm mất tích không
anh chịu
thể nhìn lại có mít của mình và cười ấy
à Nhờ Mỹ người khác nhìn mà có mít của
bé ông thì chửi chứ không cười cả
à à
Spare me Dream II Em béo cứ ngồi sữa đi
mi này
Ừ
Tốt quá đi con nít để có sữa Batman Ok
Để thử xem ví Mì Gõ cho mày ạ
công ngồi sữa thế
chống đỡ sợ nói gì vậy
Cập nhật link này đúng không
khi mua phần mềm nhũn ra nhà ở
cứ cười
cười cười sống với tôi lại đi đã từng
nhóm 1 thì lại cười thôi biết làm thế
nào nữa
nhưng mà ở đấy Nói chung à Hồi trước thì
có người tự ái có tập đều hôm bảo vệ bảo
vệ các bạn cứ nói
bởi vì mấy ông đã cố gắng hết sức khỏe
tự nhiên có người ném đá mình cần mực
thì cũng từ đáy Có nhưng mà cuộc sống
ở Bảo Lạc khi và bị nhà em thế không
phải là ông sẽ thái độ lại được thử lại
hai cái gì cả chiều không
biết được thứ nhất là là họ nói đúng hay
sai họ nói đúng thì mình phải tự rút
kinh nghiệm mình có tự tôn có mình có tự
trọng có chất hơn có chứ nhưng mà có hai
sẽ có 2 kiểu một là khi mà ông bị đau và
được lựa chọn Một là ông sẽ tiến bộ hơn
để cho người khác không bao giờ động
ngoài nữa hay là ông hiểu rất đẩy lên
chỗ ngồi cả lại trở lại ông không nên
làm hiệu cái thứ hai với thứ hai không
khiến ông khá hơn ông ạ
Nên là để ông tự ái tôi cố tình nói cho
mày không biết ai không tự 21 mà ông mực
tại
có hai loại mấy ông mãi ở đây thôi đi
mua chửi nhau với tôi nó chả giải quyết
vấn đề đấy
á nhon
Ừ đúng rồi cho
nên là tôi sẽ nói rồi đấy thức a Tôi
thích kiểu đấy tôi ngoài việc là hồi
trước tôi học thầy rồi tôi còn xem mà
Roland Golden làm sai à chị nghe Nghe
hay đi hát mà tôi cũng mua thế hay mà
cha mẹ ông Biên à mà stress rồi đúng
không Ông Golden đắm say trên nó chửi
rất nhiều với mi về đâu vậy ạ
một ngày tốt lành mới số thật tôi Cậu
muốn cối kiểu như thế này sau sẽ cho
U16 sẽ hiểu giúp đỡ người khác các cơ sở
nhưng mà vẫn chưa bị xử lý vấn chửi
vẫn cậu nói câu gấu cũng triệu cũng đau
hệ săn mồi ừ
ở nhà mày với các bạn tôi thể chưa có gì
cả chứ gì cả chấm rồi à a cho mình chị
sẽ lô D
cho cấp truy cập nhật tài liệu gì cả Ok
rồi
ngắm 27 à à
ha Tôi chở không vui à
à ừm Ông ấy bị nghe chửi tao trả luôn
vui đâu
tôi vui ở nữa tôi không quan tâm mày ông
vua được không
Ai Cập nhật từ hôm trước cũng chưa có
chưa có gì cả chưa có
đề tài liệu kê hôm qua vậy 18A
ờ ờ
ông ấy mới cũng mới cập nhật gần đây mặc
Tại sao có virus ở đây
Ừ ok cập nhật tài liệu rồi em nhé
nhà thuốc Nhầm Cô ấy là gì không
Tôi vẫn buồn cười qua lại hôm trước 2.1
6.10 Hiệp vẫn cái cũ à nó sẽ đi bê à
hồ sơ đồ thế Không vẫn chưa cầm được cái
gì cả Đây khi truy cập nhật cái à
em chưa cập nhật cái tài liệu mô phỏng
rồi à
gì có chuyện chữ vui theo cái chân nó
tên nó nói tất cả rồi chửi thẳng cũng
vui vẻ đấy cả nên đại khái thì đúng mà
ông người đa số là là là nó là con người
châm biếm
Ông Ngoại Tôi thích phong cách kiểu đấy
nó sẽ không thích phong cách kiểu Tôi là
một người nói sao không Không phải kiểu
không nịnh hót không số lệnh không có
dạng này tới nhà tôi nên nói sao cho vừa
lòng thì có nhưng mà yêu lúc rồi những
lúc làm việc ở mình phải nghiêm túc chấp
nhận mình gặp sai phải cũng như nói
thẳng vào mặt mình chứ không phải ai rồi
nó ngọt không phải nói hiểu mong rõ gì
thì cứ nói thẳng về sau anh sẽ quên được
là những người nằm thẳng đầu mà ông một
là kẻ thù ông
hay là bạn của ông
mà ta thường là cái sau nhận ra kẻ thủ ô
những người mà ghét ông ấy sẽ nói kiểu
sẽ không có bia mờ đâu thế mày thẳng Vừa
Đâu
Ừ nó bị ông để không tốt lên à không
biết trước đây
chị hỏi Lạng giảng đạo nhạc rồi quá Tại
Khánh thì buổi hôm nay được cơ à Mấy
buổi Thứ Bảy chị Thư Giãn là chủ yếu
ngồi Cận nhà thế cũng chẳng chấm đi mấy
Có vài nhóm này mai mà mai ở vài nhóm có
nhóm làm thì thôi chứ mày chữa được vào
nhóm để mấy ông Dũng nghiệm cho chính
nhóm mình à
[âm nhạc]
nghỉ
bây giờ tôi có việc rồi Chào mấy ông nha
à